[Applaudissements]
christophe beaugrand apparemment vous
êtes énervé alors après yann moix
christophe beaugrand mais oui il était
dans médias le mag sur france 5
ouais donc on lui explique légitimement
que secretstory fait pas l'unanimité et
lui répond j'ai la chance que mes
patrons ne soit pas gilles verdez alors
moi ce que je vais lui dire mon petit
christophe d'argent parce que parce que
ce que vous avez dit quelque chose vous
diriez quoi vous l'avez dit vous avez
vous la mapaq et n'est pas attaqué j'ai
dit légitimement qui n'était pas très
bon à des courses que tout le monde
pense me dit pas toujours d'accord mais
attention mon petit christophe parce
qu'un jour je serai peut-être ton patron
et si je suis ton marre on en a il faut
pas insulter l'avenir
c'est vous l'avenir
[Rires]
dans les juges distinctement qu'est ce
qui se passe avec christophe alors
dites-nous geffray donner des cours
d'animation parce que très franchement
il ya énormément de boulot qui devrait
se poser les bonnes questions si
secretstory marche pas et si ça commence
à s'effondrer
c'est vrai que ça marche pas trop elle
va ça marche pas trop parce que lui il
est vraiment de plus en plus mauvais
dans au carré bas à un moment il faut se
regarder devant le miroir faire son
bilan et moi je peux l'y aider s'il veut
parce qu'il a un peu le melon christophe
beaugrand vous vous tenez qu'il a le
melon blé déjà rencontré mais j'ai pas
besoin de le rencontrer ceux ci il
suffit de regarder non
oui vous avez vous êtes dur ce n'est pas
d'accord vous n'êtes pas d'accord ils
avaient construit cette route est un
tout petit peu excessif parce que
honnêtement il a des vraies qualités
lesquels il a des qualités d'animateur
mais lesquels
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]